[Music]
almost one month into the war ukraine
and russia are in talks to end it
however key issues need to be resolved
and the two sides are pretty far apart
president vladimir zelinski says he's
ready to ditch ukraine's membership of
nato if russia withdraws from its
territory he also says that ukrainians
now understand that nato membership is
off the table
for moscow preventing any chance of
nato's expansion in ukraine was a reason
for waging war on ukraine in the first
place
demilitarization as a kremlin calls it
but will zelensky's concession on nato
make a difference
[Music]
russia is also demanding ukraine accept
a neutral status that would provide a
guarantee ukraine wouldn't interfere in
other nations conflicts ukraine hasn't
ruled out guarantees on its own
neutrality but it is seeking guarantees
on its own security
perhaps the biggest sticking point is
territory crimea which russia annexed in
2014 and the separatist regions of
donetsk and luhansk now president
vladimir zelinsky says he's willing to
talk about those issues however for most
ukrainians handing over territory as a
reward for russian invasion is not going
to sit well yes russia wants ukraine to
recognize the annexation of crimea and
the independence of donetsk and lugansk
but this is an issue that the two sides
have been far apart on for a long time
part of vladimir putin's justification
for this war was to denatify ukraine
rooting out what he called dangerous
nationalists ukraine's jewish president
has rejected russia's use of this
language however there may well be a
deal on far-right militia groups as they
are fighting as part of the defense of
ukraine president zolensky has said that
any deal with russia needs to be put to
the people as part of a referendum so
this is only the first step of any
potential deal
[Music]